law is with us law is in Florida hi law
how are you hey Dave I'm doing great how
you doing better than I deserve what's
up hey
so my girlfriend and I are looking to
buy our first home both first-time
homebuyers and we're looking at two
properties one of them's four hundred
and thirty thousand dollars with no HOA
fees and the other ones three hundred
and sixty thousand with HOA fees and
we're wondering with the closing costs
and the HOA fees like what would be the
better investment see none of the above
you should never buy real estate with
someone you are not married to under any
circumstances I mean marriage is the
next step no married is the first was
very strong no marriage is the first
step you should never buy a property
with someone you're not married to
you're talking to an old guy who has
counseled tens of thousands of people
through some of the most bizarre and
perverted stories you've ever heard in
your life she was driving to work one
morning and got hit head-on and now I
own a house with her mother
mmm that happened she ran off with a
cheerleader from the professional sports
team she decided that she liked women
more than men she's gone now I own a
house with her and her girlfriend you
don't want this story you don't be this
guy get married before you buy a house
period or one of you buy the house and
if you want a roommate that's your
decision but I I please do not do this
sir in this order you are going to
create a problem in your life that you
didn't need to you don't act like you're
married when you're not married it
creates all kinds of problems legally
financially relationally morally
financially legally relationally morally
guys here's the thing money decisions
when you are doing them together or not
together married or not married changes
the dynamic of the relationship it is
like the law of gravity you don't get to
choose to not participate in the law of
gravity all snowflakes end up in a pile
because of the law of gravity they're
unique but they're uniquely all in a
pile because of the law of gravity they
are subject to the law of gravity there
are laws in finance and in personal
finance and in relationships any time
you borrow money from someone you change
the relationship with that person the
old joke is if I loan my brother-in-law
$100 in he never speaks to me again was
it worth it it changes their
relationship when you borrow money from
your daddy for a car Thanksgiving dinner
tastes different until you get your
daddy paid off because he just became
your master the borrower is slave to the
lender and you're not the exception folk
no one is trying to protect you I don't
want you get hurt I want you to live
your life the best possible way you can
and I'm going to give you the advice the
best I can to cause that to happen for
you